Luke here the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel and me and my family we're here
on the island of Maui and we're
snorkeling spear fishing catching and
cooking lobsters eating good food and
we're having a great time
[Music]
[Applause]
you tell me you want to help me go get
breakfast
yeah
we must find sustenance for the family
well everyone back home is going to be
hungry when they wake up so we're gonna
get some breakfast
okay all right we got some passion fruit
juice French toast spam and eggs we've
got a Hawaiian dish called Loco Moco
which is Sunnyside Up egg on a hamburger
patty with gravy and rice and then we've
got half a dozen deep fried Portuguese
malasadas
[Music]
and those are me sketching the beach
good morning Becca
are you glad to be in Hawaii
who's ready for some malasadas I am oh
malasadas are a Portuguese donut that's
become very popular here in Hawaii these
are filled with cream but some are
filled with guava jelly and passion
fruit
that taste good
yep just finishing breakfast we're gonna
see two whales breaching out in the
water out there
well I'm gonna go grab Tommy and run a
few errands is that all right
okay
we gotta go do some grocery shopping and
get supplies for the family all right
I'll let you grab which flavors you want
oh passion fruit juice
oh I love lihimui powder
that one looks good all right
here will you run this card over
those so
you want one it's called The ninari
Sushi it's sweet fried tofu around rice
like that
that's good
it is a beautiful day and I'm going to
be meeting with a guide to go spear
fishing something I absolutely love to
do when I'm here in Hawaii and I'm
excited to go
hey cool how you doing I'm good Luke
nice to meet you
all right
now conditions were not very good for
spearfishing on this day but Kua took me
to a spot where he thought we might get
a shot at a moo and we spent a bit of
time chasing a fish called AMU we baited
up the water with some Chum I tried
scratching but it just didn't work out
but this spot was full of a fish called
kolei or yellow eye and it's one of my
favorite fish to eat so we decided that
we're gonna get out the three prong and
try it to get a bunch of kolei
unfortunately it's been almost a year
since I've used the three prong and I am
Rusty
eventually I managed to get some fish
and things started to click and we had a
great time
even Kua got in on the action and he
speared a benini and a bunch of kolei
and before you know it we had a Stringer
full of fish which was brilliant because
kolei is really delicious and I'd
promised my good friend Patrick that I
would come over to his house and do a
fish fry so me and Kua both brought home
Plenty of Fish for our families
this has been awesome we've got a ton of
collate which are one of my favorite
fish we're gonna just start swimming
back to Shore and see what we see along
the way
out here
oh
oh that was fun but I'm really glad we
went out there I had a load of fun just
shooting some Kool-Aid with that
three-prong
here we go here's the Colace they're
still on the Stringer you want to check
those out actually if you wanted to help
you can pull those off the streamer
let's see okay so we can bread them up
yeah and then holy
[Music]
[Applause]
are you this plate right there yeah wait
a minute so this is poi it's fermented
taro root it's a traditional Hawaiian
food
it's got a really subtle flavor it kind
of reminds me of really like really
toned down sour cream
oh
oh that was good food I think we just
need to sit here and digest for a little
bit what do you think babe yeah
well this is the up country farmers
market and I've had three different
people tell me we should check it out so
here we are
here those are pretty good yeah yeah oh
look at that we get some green bananas
and loquats
this is an apple banana it's they're so
sweet you always want them when they're
popping open and a little bit Brown
ice cream Bean it's it's just a bean
that comes from a big tree
that is a weird texture but it's sweet
it's like eating a really lightly
flavored marshmallow good
is that like a soursop it's a sweet
sauce so yeah same thing but sweet
version of it
all right there's the Kihei swap meet
Maui rotisserie chicken yes we're
driving down the road looking for lunch
and the smell just hit us got a whole
bunch of ribs and chicken here this is
gonna be great
yeah here pass one back to Jacob they're
all the same that's yours oh ribs
we're the type of people that don't like
crowds and so we've got this cute little
beach here called one beach and uh we're
gonna give it a go let's see what it
looks like
we'll be planning this trip for a while
and I've been telling my friend Patrick
and his son Axel that I would take them
out spear fishing so on this trip we
decided to make sure that they got a
chance to learn how to spear fish so I
got the three prong out gave Patrick a
kind of a rundown of how to spear fish
and we sent him after a bunch of Colette
we got him
well I promised Tommy that I'd take him
spear fishing so once Patrick and axel
had their fish I got the spear gun out
loaded it up and showed Tommy how to
shoot it and we sent him after some Cola
I'm proud of Tommy spear fishing is
harder than it looks and he kept after
it and eventually he managed to shoot
this beautiful niana
there you go he nailed him
yes good Tommy shot a fish
yeah you got it
watch out here
big one oh that was fun
did they tell you have my uh memory card
was corrupted with uh one with all my
footage for the trip so far
yeah I think he got my uh I got a crack
in the screen of my GoPro and the water
got it
thank you
there you go
I said I was home with you guys you get
to eat your first kill yes I'll tell you
what this is just a wonderful Beach it's
just absolutely fabulous snorkeling and
almost nobody here
but we had such a great time Tommy shot
his first fish showed it Axel and
Patrick it's a great place to snorkel
and play on the beach but it's getting
late and it's Nathan's birthday so I
think it's time to go home get some cake
John what do you think was that fun yes
congratulations you're a spear fisherman
let's go
it's a pretty cool beach if you want to
come here or do any of the things we do
in this video check the video
description for links and more
information
yeah we need to take a shower we're
gross we had a good day so day so far
get that to work
got a bit of a problem while I was out
snorkeling today my GoPro cracked and it
led in water and it fried the memory
card and the GoPro and all the footage
from the first three days of here in
Maui has been corrupted going forward I
have no idea of whether or not you guys
are going to see any of that footage so
yeah we're gonna have to do some
hardcore data recovery when we get back
can't let it ruin things you know we
gotta just move forward should we start
opening birthday presents and then you
ready yeah
yeah all right
oh I see General's leaving bag
[Music]
happy birthday
to you
we had a lot of fun got a lot of sunburn
and had a little boy who turned eight
not a bad day
good morning Nathan my little bird
victims oh curse are overwhelmingly good
ability to process vitamin D
lots of sunscreen being applied right
now
well it's Sunday morning so that means
we're hurting cats off to church come on
come on let's go let's go
everyone keep your pants on and try not
to embarrass us all right guys we're
here at church time to put the camera
down I'll see you in a little bit see it
was really funny we ran into several
people we knew at church including the
family of a close friend back home
should we go get some lunch
yes
all right everyone out well we're
hanging out here with the South family
again
check it out I changed into my Hawaiian
Church uh hybrid outfit here
[Music]
there's kind of is all right guys we got
a beautiful little Sunday lunch here we
got some roasted chicken we've got some
pork and water chestnut lettuce wraps
and we got some grilled veggies I
actually get some Fiber into my boys
oh I'm gonna try this out
was that delicious you're delicious all
right we're gonna do some dessert we got
this Hawaiian jalapia mix we're gonna
make
just let that cool down I'm starting the
healing process from losing all my
footage
slowly but it's happening let's see how
we're going
what is it boogers
do you know how much I had to sneeze to
fill this pan all right let's pop this
out here we want to grab the other pan
anyone under
is good it's 25 of your daily sugar
intake of course it's good to try you go
do you like the booger brownies
to get uh
the day just flew by we've had just a
great time hanging out and enjoying the
weather together and talking thanks for
coming bye
bye well we've had a great time hanging
out with the South family and just
enjoying this low-key day but we gotta
get to bed we're getting up really early
to go do a pretty awesome adventure
tomorrow all right
the bed
foreign
guys we're going on a little snorkeling
trip with ocean Riders we're gonna head
off across the open ocean to the island
of Lanai and we're going to go
completely around the island of Lanai
we're gonna get to see shipwrecks and
snorkeling and I might even get to do
some spear fishing it's gonna be awesome
oh there's just whales everywhere
probably a half a dozen or more we've
seen already
oh yeah
I will
oh
we've seen so many whales so far I think
it's already been like 15 whales
is pretty normal
yep it's another day at the office these
humpback whales spend the winter down
here and have their calves and then they
go up to Alaska in the summertime
[Music]
this one made it right in between Maui
check out this shipwreck it's a World
War II era Liberty ship made of concrete
and rebar in 1956 they were Towing it
for Salvage and it washed up on this
Reef
that is cool Nate did you want some
snacks these are linghibuy gummies
gummies
Old World War II Arrow landing craft the
military used to practice with that's
cool
I think we beat the crowds all right you
guys ready to go on the beach
we're heading for the beach You're Next
Mama
oh yeah it comes Jay big old crab holes
it's kind of cool be the first person to
put footprints on the beach
you fight a coconut
look at that you're there oh yeah let's
see nothing's inside
nothing inside
it's for Mama started swimming back to
the boat
go down the coast and go find a place to
snorkel
look at that water
sure
I was really excited to go spearfishing
off the coast of Lanai the water is so
clear and there's just tons of fish the
first fish I saw was actually an
invasive Roy this grouper here eats a
lot of native Hawaiian fish and
generally anytime you get a chance to
shoot one you take it there's some big
Ben punching that
but the number one fish I wanted to
shoot on this trip was a moo or a
big-eyed Emperor and they didn't live in
really deep water and be hard to
approach so I hid down this rock and I
try to get as close to these two moves I
could
and I still missed
well maybe you have a good time had a
great time do you see lots of fish lots
of fish lots of lots of coral it's great
did you hear the whales I did well
should we try another spot sure let's do
it
oh this looks pretty nice I think we
might hop in and try to poke a fish
in this second spot I dove down and
almost immediately saw a gray Snapper or
an uku I went ahead and took a shot at
him but my line got tangled up in my
bands and it ripped the spear right off
the gun
now I recovered my spear about all the
tools to repair it were back at the
condo so my spear gun was done for the
day and so I grabbed my three pong and
decided to go look for some mempachi or
a squirrel fish or something and I'm
poking around the caves and wouldn't you
know it there's a moo 10 feet of water
super close that's the close this I've
ever been to a boo that's that's a
little heartbreaking
now shortly thereafter I saw this goat
fish attacking an eel and he was so busy
he didn't notice me and I got him
go fish tastes great and they're an
excellent fish to steam
right after that I saw this eagle ray
and I gotta dive down and swim right
above it it was really cool it's about
four feet across and then down in this
cave I saw a big long john squirrelfish
and uh got him
another delicious fish
Jacob had to poop overboard and the
trigger fish would be going bonkers ever
since
it'll bolt will squish you
oh all these different activities we're
doing we're gonna put links in the video
description below so you guys can do
them too if you want
all right Tom you want to go fishing
love you babe
hey Patrick all right let's do some
fishing
if we're gonna go fishing we need to
catch some bait
I got a good chance this is a Hawaiian
style throw net
when you pull the leash it doesn't close
up like the ones we use in lower 48.
yeah
well no luck on the cast net we're gonna
keep moving down the trail and see if we
can find some bait
oh look at that yeah
we can eat that
yeah a little manini these are actually
good eating fish I don't think I've ever
had one of those daddy they're like a
Kool-Aid yeah
okay
what happened there bud
in my butt here here let me let me help
you
he did I think the fish has tapeworms oh
yeah look at that it's it's moving
these worms are crawling out of the fish
that's poo right there yeah that's it's
that's it's coming out of its stomach
got a little rig with a big hook with a
piece of manini and a little hook with a
piece of shrimp
nice I got the camera yeah I can see him
that's a squirrel fish
ing they're really good
I've eaten them this size before you fry
them up just like those koley
pretty little
we keep getting snagged and losing our
leads
see if see if this will work as a lead
yeah you got this little little guy a
fish there you go another one of these
little guys sometimes we cut a whole
bucket full of them you know he made it
well Tommy and axel have been cooking
stuff over the fire and they just uh ate
a suicidal crab that ran across the
beach into the fires oh this has been
fun Tom but I think Mom probably is
wondering where we're at oh thanks for
coming hanging out with me man
so you've got some Dicky little fish but
we got something to eat we're gonna make
a meal today yeah thank you so much for
giving us those
all right was that fun Tommy that was
loads of fun I have zero regrets
well guys it's late and I'm exhausted
I'll see you guys in the morning we got
more fun stuff tomorrow
who's hungry
[Music]
shave ice is not something you usually
eat for breakfast
it's really good
enough because I've never tried one
here you got some rambleton
grab an apple banana you want the
squishy ones are the best
okay Jake
what do you guys want to eat next
pineapple salsa is pretty amazing mom's
got the chips all right we've got
pineapple Bagels some passion fruit
cream cheese
oh
all right guys we're in the city of
Lahaina and uh we're gonna go right on
the submarine
[Music]
hundreds of fish
he's just laying there on the bottom
we're heading into a hole
shark over here on the board side he's
just laying there for that big-eyed
Emperor or the blue fish is coming up
good good we have a spotted eagle ray
coming through is a giant trolley over
here on the port side Giants are always
will actually go up against the Sharks
Sports side you're getting the view of
the carthaginian Wounded decided to sell
oh my
see there's no red
five foot underwater
see your shirt's red again
not even a double
stranger things
okay
take it out this is all one giant banyan
tree I remember playing on this thing
when I was a kid little Roots come off
the branches hit the ground and start
new trunks yeah sure I'll try the lychee
hey can I try your tiger blood Nathan
device with ice cream is
if you watch my videos you know I love
to cook so me and Becca are having a
Thai Chef come to our condo to teach us
how to make Thai food and to make a Thai
meal for us having a personal chef come
to your rental and make some awesome
food for you is only marginally more
expensive than going to a restaurant and
you get to learn how to make an awesome
meal it's actually a really cool
experience the big downside is that our
place is an absolute disaster and now we
have to hurry clean up
all right
oh I've got sand and weird places
look at Panic cleaning got the job done
hi I'm Luke yeah
yeah
and palm sugar tastes a little bit
different
I just want to go on it so quickly
that's fine
so let's say about last time my very
first Pad Thai there it doesn't look
horrible all right now we're gonna learn
how to make a Thai curry
make sure the fish
that's not spicy at all yeah oh now
you're just showing off yeah it's
beautiful babe is this fun is it so fun
yeah it's nice and we get to do
something that's kind of a little
different doesn't involve getting sand
in our hair they taste so good and it
tastes really good all right guys you
want to try some of this yes what
they're not what do you think you like
it which one you like the best the
noodles or the curry
that was so much fun thank you bye-bye
that's a load of food as always guys
I'll put links in the video description
below if you want to do this too now
this Trip's awesomeness just went up
another level here we are eating fresh
made Thai food
looking at that view works
we're just sitting here and there's a
sea turtle up on the beach and another
one right in the surf
it's gonna be late
I'm here with my good friend Kua and I'm
gonna do something I've been wanting to
do for a long time we're gonna go for
Hawaiian lobsters thanks for taking me
out here you're welcome man
all right guys into the darkness
[Music]
so this is a pony yeah
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
something
oh that is a big bag of lobster my legs
are bad oh I bet they are oh bad yeah
bad that was awesome
oh
Happy Easter
look at that
look at that look at those hug season
yeah that's a good mug got a feast
I can see one
two three four five six seven eight nine
ten eleven
they're so pretty
well I only got four that's for sure oh
thank you again no this is awesome man
there we go that's that's a view
the selfie Lobster bag grab an extra
towel
was that a good day for you and average
day what do you think
this today grabbing girls all night
11 boys
um you know for the family thanks guys
oh
well good morning guys after four hours
of sleep I've woken up to whales jumping
outside of our condo
oh look at this it's laughing you guys
there's a whale here they're doing a
high five to the ocean he's waving at us
we're taking the lobsters let's go
[Music]
yes yes
take the tater tots and the ketchup
feel like so maybe
that is good Tommy you get some because
you helped is that good
we're here
all right let's check out what we got
here
oh
we've got shredded pork with venison
sausage the Huli Huli chicken with
barbecued ribs barbecued chicken wings
with pork belly a local Fern salad and
vegetables and we got some cornbread and
of course some tater tots it looks
pretty good doesn't it that looks great
very interesting
hard to find places I am very full of
food and very tired
[Applause]
well we've gotta go take a picture for
this video's thumbnail and I'm exhausted
so Becca's gonna drive but we're gonna
go to a nice pretty beach
[Music]
I can't move dada
ah help me
I give you a smiley face
okay come on out buddy I get the
lobsters out of your way
oh we took some pictures with the
lobsters for our thumbnail now the kids
are playing in the title pool and
Becca's painting and it's a nice easy
afternoon
all right Thomas you ready to do some
night diving yeah I'm a glutton for
punishment I'm gonna go night diving two
nights in a row I'll sleep when I get
back home
all right we got Rebecca and bran here
with Shoreline snorkel and they're gonna
be taking me Tommy Patrick and his son
Axel out on a night dive awesome well
we're stoked
[Music]
foreign
Roblox
[Music]
what'd you think was that awesome that
was awesome but those caterpillar cleats
creatures scared me half to death
you like stand up late and going
snorkeling with me yes all right we'll
have to do that again sometime and as
always I'll put links in the video
description to all these activities
we're doing
well good morning Becca good morning are
you ready to go scuba diving I hope so
all right let's do it we have to wrestle
the children into the car first
all right Becca are you gonna film this
I gotta try okay we'll see how it goes
love you hey I'm here with Ashley with
Maui diving hi everybody we're here at
McKenna Landing hey we're gonna do a
Shore dive we're gonna enter in over
there in the beach and we're gonna swim
over and go dive at the five caves over
there
[Music]
thank you
all right
[Music]
that was so cool though oh hey America
I saw sharks we went in a cave I saw a
turtle we brought you some malasadas
you have fun I had a great time we got
some lobsters to cook up you guys want
to go eat some lunch yeah
you ready for some lobsters
hello
it's so sticky pull out the flesh like
that
that's good
tastes like a canned Peach maybe there
you go yeah yeah you can eat the seeds
too this gives us little bits of Flesh
around the seeds it's just this really
fruity flavor it's like almost like a
Gummy Bear fruity yeah should we cook up
some lobsters yeah let's do it all right
let's do it
all right they won't have to suffer as
well you might start
here in Hawaii
take some of these wedges get that lime
juice in there all right I'm stealing an
adamoya from Patrick's fruit stash here
kind of a custardy citrusy flavor
they're they're good
um this one's a little bit override it
looks like crab meat yeah though it
looks like blue crab body meat though to
me yeah yeah take all the meat make a
nice little pile right there
oh
yeah
look at that butter lime and shirt
Chernobyl
oh my gosh it tastes like a lime key
lime pie yeah almost
there we go
oh don't worry okay
and you can see they're getting quite
cook it all the way through you see that
that's raw right there yeah yeah but
just in the thickest part so it's like
80 90 yeah throw the legs in here
all right
that's okay
yeah it's like I cut one tree down
oh look at the flowers too
that's your French disease
serious
oh my god oh it's so good like that babe
Foster
oh guys it's been an absolutely lovely
day and it's kind of a reminder that
sometimes I overthink these trips I
think the kids just like playing in the
yard with friends more than just about
anything else we've done just learn from
my mistakes don't overthink these
vacations you know we have chatted the
kids have played and the sun has set has
been wonderful it's been great all right
kids come on did you have fun yeah yeah
it's been so nice playing with friends
has that been your favorite part of the
trip yes
your destination is on the right all
right we're gonna check out the Homemade
Bakery here
peanut butter monkey coconut mochi
you want the coconut one
[Music]
all right look is it apple and coconut
turnover we got coconut almond and sweet
potato ampod look at this we have
coconut Mochi and we have deep fried
Manju and then we have Emo oh filled
crispy Manju
oh that looks good
hey it's the best turnover I've had in a
long time oh that's coconut
try some coconut ampon
we are good
Ube is so good head on down to the car
guys headed on down
well Becca I really wanted to do a
little drive up the Yale Valley and
we're gonna go to kapani Y Park
all right babe you want to go explore
while I watch the kids
oh they have a Japanese tea house and a
koi pond pretty
there's the tea house so pretty with the
valley tree that is gorgeous and there's
chicken so that's fun too okay that's
fine but we gotta go we have places to
be
well I've got a close friend back home
whose parents run a fruit farm here on
Maui and uh we're gonna go check it out
and visit it because I love me some
fresh fruit
thank you
oh it looks this silver beautiful
there's a guava tree lots of guava
so this is the guava tree
how do you tell which ones are good
the yellow ones
that's actually really good they're good
oh they just fall off really those ones
just came off really easy yeah
look at that see
[Music]
I know you had a banana
I'll try that
um
this is a sweet sub
a sour sauce throughout no no this whole
piece is yours
the soursop right
yeah here try the soursop it's good
the light there's a banana tree back
there yeah check it out the mangoes and
that's dragon fruit
yeah this is banana you can see this is
the banana flower the rabutan tree yeah
these are robutan they're furry Rye
cheese
these are amazing
crack of open like this looks like a
little eyeball or something
they're just a little pit inside there
this big lake
here you go
that's good that's the better that's
better than the ones we bought at the
store yeah yeah
there you go hey guys you made it
check it out we're robiton harvesting
look at this guava down here there's one
right there and there's a good one right
there
really good I think I might be the best
in my family check it out this is a low
quad tree it's Japanese I think either
they're Bima or Pima or something
yeah being from Alaska I'm still amazed
that food grows on trees
times either
this is called
[Music]
you guys
Ponderosa lemon that is a huge lemon
this is cassava this is what they make
tapioca out of it's a edible root
oh they usually hang close look at that
little baby Jackfruit this is that same
enormous fruit we ate yesterday just a
little little growing baby version
I see
this is what short people use oh that's
cool
you think of these are papaya trees
right here
oh wow we call this apple guava because
you bite it it's crunchy like you're
eating an apple they're cutting down the
banana tree to get all those bananas
oh look at that that is cool
those little apple bananas are the best
bananas
look at the size of that guava that's
huge you guys think you could pick some
guavas
song
with like like the Jazz and this right
here is a pomelo fruit you get the size
of a soccer ball and tastes like
grapefruit this is a breadfruit tree the
blossoms smell like Jasmine
oh it's so good
[Applause]
look at this this is a breadfruit
come and pick it you you fit by turning
it twisting it oh oh look at your bread
fruit you've harvested breadfruit they
look kind of like an Osage orange they
have no writing on the roof no writing
on the roof
I think it's got the machete
right here
stuff's like burlap it's stronger than
that here it's good for starting fires
yeah I'll meet you back at the table
you guys ready to knock this elephant oh
yeah try this oh yeah yeah
[Music]
yeah it's really good
split in half now
all the Coconuts
there you go beef oh right there
Nathan what are you doing Nathan what
have I told you about making lingerie
out of your food
oh thank you so much this has been
wonderful all right boys get in the car
okay thanks Patrick it's been good to
see you bud that was so awesome we're
gonna do more videos
well I thank you very much River
our friends have let us eat all their
fruit and then now they've invited us
into their house for dinner so uh we're
taking the kids over for a nice
home-cooked meal and we're really
excited
we've got salmon noodle salad the
makizushi
namasu and mochi
you like that
thank you
a good night all right bacon should we
go to the airport let's go to the
airport
[Music]
oh we made it home are you tired babe
yes well hopefully you guys aren't tired
of seeing our videos and if that's the
case don't forget to click subscribe and
don't forget to check out our travel
Adventure playlist for More Travel
adventures with the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel alright guys I'll see you next
Saturday if you like this video don't
forget to check out the outdoor Boys
YouTube channel where we have hundreds
of videos just like this and don't
forget to click subscribe so you can see
other great videos every Saturday
morning and hit that Bell button you'll
get notifications thanks for watching
[Music]